I got a number of emails from folks over
the weekend
saying David we don't have to worry
about the Senate anymore we don't have
to worry about the Senate because Adam
laxalt was defeated by Cortez masto in
Nevada
and Democrats now have guaranteed
a majority 50 50 in the Senate and that
is true but 51 versus 50 is of massive
importance 51 means that Joe manchin or
Kirsten cinema right but Joe manchin's
been the bigger problem is no longer
necessary on votes that require a simple
majority and it means you only need nine
Republicans instead of ten when you need
60 votes in the Senate this cannot be
understated so let's talk through it
when it comes to federal judges as an
example it is of critical importance
that Democrats control the Senate
and Democrats do and those are simple
majorities and generally speaking
neither Joe manchin or Kirsten Cinema
have been obstacles when it comes to
those sorts of votes but there are all
sorts of other bills and proposals where
Mansion has been a problem and Mansion
has done the rounds on the Sunday shows
and has made himself into this decider
for lack of a better term because
Democrats were able to coalesce 49 votes
but not 50 specifically because of Joe
manchin if indeed Raphael Warnock
defeats Herschel Walker in the December
6th runoff one Senator you could take
your pick Mansion or Cinema no longer
matters when you simply need 50 plus
Kamala Harris's tie-breaking vote
there's another really important reason
why this runoff is still important even
though Democrats now control the Senate
either way
and that is that 2024 is a much more
difficult Senate map and Georgia would
be one seat that does not have to be won
in 2024 in order to maintain a majority
consider that we've been talking about
the 2024 senate election for years 33
Senate seats are up in 2024 and it is
not a good map for Democrats Democrats
have to defend seats in Montana Ohio and
West Virginia John tester in Montana a
Democrat Montana is very very red he won
with 50.3 percent last time really
really Slim margin Sherrod Brown in Ohio
a Democrat one with 53 percent in 2018 a
little more margin there but still not
an easy race and then in West Virginia
Joe manchin won with under 50 think
about that with under 50 and with Joe
manchin and West Virginia being such a
red State we don't even know whether Joe
manchin is is running yet I don't have
the latest uh I believe the latest
information is Mansion is not yet
committed to running in 2024 if Mansion
doesn't run
and it comes down to a further left
Democrat versus a republican in West
Virginia
it very well may be that that is a seat
that Democrat my earpiece is flopping
all over that even me may be a seat that
Democrats uh potentially give up so the
Senate map is so tough in 2024 that
controlling the senate in 24 may depend
on whether Raphael Warnock or Herschel
Walker win on December 6th so I I think
I'm making the stakes pretty clear here
last thing on this imagine if for the
last two years
Democrats had had 51 rather than 50
votes and the number of bills on which
the entire circus Sideshow with Joe
manchin could have been skipped
altogether so this is still an
absolutely critical runoff for different
reasons than it was critical 48 or 72
hours ago we're going to be doing live
streams getting involved in that race
many of you are saying I actually should
go to Georgia
I just don't know that I can do it in in
the next you know couple weeks with
everything I have going on but we are
going to do as much as we can on that
race and more information about that
upcoming